notre panel ce soir avec madeleine blé
mort est notre collègue michel serrault
g et al crh françois raoult toi pourquoi
on va commencer par le dossier de
l'ukraine évidemment ces incontournables
nouvelle annonce encore aujourd'hui du
canada nouvelles livraisons d'armes pour
l'ukraine nouvelles sanctions avec des
tarifs de 35 % sur les importations de
la russie du belarus et la ministre que
ce fut l'un qui a annoncé que le canada
va faciliter maintenant l'accès aux
réfugiés ukrainien avec une espèce de
procédure un peu rapide le bouillon n'ya
pas de nombre limite et on dit vous
pouvez rester jusqu'à deux ans il sait
sur le territoire de nouvelles sanctions
aussi on va l'écouter
les membres de l'élite financiers russes
peuvent croire que le lien étroite avec
les conseils d'administration et les
yachts clubs d'occident les protégés
rang mais ils entourent nous ne
laisserons pas les russes et les
institutions russes qui sont centraux
dans la kleptocratie déchu du président
poutine jouir de cette prospérité
j'ai commencé avec vous parlons du rôle
de la ministre füle and vice première
ministre
elle fait une immense différence dans ce
dossier d'abord par sa connaissance fine
et pointue des enjeux elles par
l'ukrainien elle parle le russe elle est
de toutes les rencontres
est ce que le canada en ferait autant
s'il n'était pas là madame fund très
bonne question voyez vous que ce film ne
dit aujourd'hui que après l'annexion de
la crimée elle avait été une de celles
qui disaient il ne faut plus mettre nos
oeufs dans le panier de la russie et
c'est pour ça qu'on a un commerce avec
la russie qui est pas si important
aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça qu'on peut
imposer des sanctions comme ça sans que
ça fasse très mal à l'économie
canadienne ça nous coûte pas très cher
en ce moment imposer ce genre de
sanction mais en même temps elles sont
importants si on veut participer à cette
bataille là qui peut être crucial pour
l'avenir du canada dans l'ordre mondial
qu'on connaît en ce moment le canada
c'est pas une super puissance donc le
canada bénéficie de règles du jeu qui
sont claires et qui sont respectés parce
que si ce sont les pays qui ont les plus
gros bras qui gagne systématiquement ça
nous nuirait donc le coach rinaldo une
influence maintenant mêlant de une
finalement qui remonte à il ya quelques
années déjà et on voit quel point elle
est là elle est une figure marquante
dans la politique canadienne en ce
moment quand vous voyez le point de
presse ce matin avec ces sanctions là où
était justin trudeau il a participé à un
autre point 13 plus tard mais on
s'attendrait à ce que ça soit le premier
ministre annonce ce genre de mesure
l'homme et c'était crucial finale qu'on
voyait à l'avant scène mais michel ça
donne un peu l'impression qu'elle vole
la vedette au premier ministre non parce
que toute l'attention on l'attend
toujours il ya pas une trace de madame
puis l'aisne en cours devant nos
télévisions pour l'écouter
si si le premier ministre déploie là
c'est parce qu'il ne veut pas être là et
si madame frills md losc police le veut
aussi je pense qu'il me laisse beaucoup
de place un moment donné oui il ya déjà
des gens qui commencent à dire justin
trudeau s'il a encore le goût d'être
premier ministre est ce que c est ce qui
prépare son départ c'est lui mais
relançons quoi une bonne chose pour lui
et pour le gouvernement il faudrait
qu'il soit un peu plus présent mais
jusqu'à un certain point madame prélable
même si
les sanctions cela relève aussi du
ministère des finances même si l or une
connaissance extrêmement film d'aussi il
reste que si la vice-première vide et
c'est pas le premier ministre et il ya
une espèce de zone de dow jones mais de
craie que madame wenham fait de l'ombre
bonne chose ni pour être des pour lui
comment vous voyez la situation vaut
elle tient
même suis pas certaine si je suis
d'accord je répète la même opinion si le
premier ministre avait posté un point de
presse une heure après celui de mal à me
fait vraiment diminuer l'immigration
chan fraser jeu pour ce premier point de
presse était en fait d'exposer le point
de presse d'hier
puisqu'elle a été reportée à aujourd'hui
pour ajouter les détails sur la nouvelle
procédure pouvoir accueillir des
réfugiés ukrainien
je pense que ça laisse les détails plus
techniques aux ministres qui sont plus
dans les détails puisque c'est leur
propre portefeuille haut puis les
questions
plus larges et pourquoi est-ce qu'on en
mette en
rampant d'ukraine pour faire un couvre
le ciel comme le demande le gouvernement
que je laisse d'action
exactement ceux des questions plus
larges wasquehal et la ligne c'était à
part le je pense que ça s'était plutôt
pour le premier ministre la direction et
puis les détails pour une ministre que
je pense que c'est on en met un petit
peu beaucoup là parce qu'on veut voir
les enjeux politiques et la relève
peut-être du parti libéral mais je
dirais que oui madrilènes ont fait
beaucoup mais c'est surtout le fait que
y'a quand même un point quatre millions
de canadiens d'origine ukrainienne au
pays qui mènent nos politique étrangère
à ce point mais qu'elle fait part si
madame freine aussi de sept actuellement
elle est issue de parole qui faisait
partie de les espoirs comme telles
paroles de jean charest parce qu il faut
vraiment se plonger dans le sujet jean
charest hier qui a eu un entretien avec
des députés des sénateurs conservateurs
à ottawa il était là et paraît-il que
tout ça ça parle beaucoup avec sa
conjointe avec son fils aussi il s'est
adressé aux journalistes on peut écouter
un extrait
un sujet sur lesquels je pense on voit
tout s'entend de l'importance et la
responsabilité du parti conservateur du
canada envers le pays ça veut dire un
parti politique
qui est fidèle à son histoire et qui
représentent chaque région du canada et
qui présente une vision qui est très
inclusif du canada
bon michel il applaudit encore s'il se
lance ou pas dans la course mais quand
on sait des propos comme il en a tenu
est-ce qui a encore un suspense
quand il arrive à ottawa avec sa femme
il se refuse pas ce qu'on disait que le
dernier une secte c'était le conseil de
famille ça veut dire qu'ils vont être
candidat je pense qu'il ya plus personne
qui en doutent il a tardé les règles et
dans le thé publié un peu plus tard que
sept internationaux vous nous avez
montré hier soir ça c'est cette espèce
de poids qu'un tranché en deux c'est à
dire qu'il oui le congrès aura lieu
au moins 2 au mois de septembre mais en
même temps il faut que tous les nouveaux
membres soit devenue femme dans trois
mois exactement le 3 juin ça c'est très
long pour monsieur charest ça va
demander une très grosse organisation
alors monsieur poignet va gagner sur sur
un point ce que charest gagner sur
l'autre on verra qui se sur ceux ci est
capable de développer en trois mois une
organisation suffisant pour faire
rentrer des ventes drouot à ce niveau au
niveau il doit le faire parce qu'il est
d'accord que si le même push up actuel
de surpoids lièvre
gagnerait facilement et d'autre part ben
je suis poli abouchi capable de fascines
comment on va les regarder plus en
détail les fameuses règles justement qui
ont été rendus publics à cette heure là
quand même hier soir alors les dates
butoirs elles sont inscrits ici 19 avril
c'est la date limite pour le dépôt des
candidatures 3 juin date limite pour
devenir membre donc avoir le droit de
voter et le vote c'est le 10 septembre
altière donc comme michel le dit
monsieur monsieur charest il attendait
de connaître les règles
une fois les règles connues il évalue
ces sages ou à son avantage à votre avis
est ce que tout ça effectivement ça lui
donne le temps dont il a besoin pour
avoir des membres qui vont voter pour
lui
oui on me dit au début de semaine même
avant qu'il était connu que monsieur
charest même si monsieur poignet
gagnerait un vote au mois de juin
monsieur charest serait quand même dans
la course alors je pense qu'on se dit
apte à une annonce plus détaillée avec
d'attention médiatique que juste
l'annoncer tahoua mercredi soir mais il
est certainement dans la cour je pense
que la question maintenant de bien est
ce que patrick brown le maire de bram
ténu qui s'est battu comme la loi 21e
rang dans la course est ce que tu as
chaque et organes mais c'est surtout est
ce que monsieur braderont pas la course
parce que monsieur g il est bien ancrée
dans les communautés ethniques en
ontario surtout mais aussi à travers le
pays puis monsieur charest il monsieur
brown aurait besoin d'environ 100 à 200
demandes de nouveaux membres pour
pouvoir gagner la course à la chefferie
si monsieur brown se lance dans la
course puis monsieur charest est en
avance ce monsieur ban des gens là vont
probablement voter pour monsieur charest
parce que c'est des gens qui sont quand
même de la même philosophie une
philosophie sont veut dire ce que ça
pousse ça pourrait l'aider ce monsieur
bande de site de port entrée dans la
course bon mais là le travail de
monsieur charest devient beaucoup plus
difficile
madeleine pierre poilievre lui il aurait
bien voulu avoir une course qui se
termine plutôt finalement parce que là
ça aurait joué en sa faveur pierre
poilievre vous laisse jouer la stratégie
du rouleau compresseur c'est pour ça
qu'il s'est lancé lui très très très tôt
dans la course 1 samedi soir il ya
publié jeudi ou dans les médias sociaux
et c'était ça son grand lancement alors
que le monsieur charest lui utilise une
stratégie qui est tout autre en essayant
de se faire désirer en n'annonçant pas
exactement quand il veut se lancer
quoique je m'attends à ce que ça soit
très bientôt là au cours des prochains
jours maintenant qu'on connaît les
règles de la course ça va être une
course qui va être très intéressante à
surveiller
effectivement la clé elle va se jouer
dans les trois prochains mois est ce que
jean charest est capable de vendre des
cartes de membres ça va se résumer
beaucoup à ça vendre les cartes de
membres au québec vendre des cartes de
membre en atlantique va on voudrait des
cartes de membre en ontario en
colombie-britannique
là où ça va compter beaucoup mais au
delà de vendre des cartes demande saas
et les sas et l'enjeu numéro un pourrait
lui va quand même falloir qu'ils
s'expliquent sur des positions passées
auprès de certains conservateurs sur ce
qui est pour ce qui est de la taxe sur
le carbone entre autres pour ce qui est
du registre des armes à feu lors ce
qu'avait laissé entendre qu'ils
pourraient peut-être se lancer lors de
la dernière course et qui avait changé
d'idée
il avait dit bon il ya certaines
positions au que je ne renierai pas
qu'ils ne sont peut-être plus
compatibles je paraphrase peut-être
grossièrement mais qui sont peut-être
plus compatible avec le parti
d'aujourd'hui donc comment il va
expliquer ses positions là comment il va
convaincre de le parti de rester unie
malgré tout si c'est lui qui gagne la
direction du parti sans il va falloir
qu'ils l'expliquent quand même aux
membres du parti conservateur et il est
quand même entré d'avoir des appuis qui
sont peut-être un peu surprenant en fait
michel qu'est ce que vous en pensez
qu'on entend parler de l'ancien ministre
libéral du québec sam hamad qui
déboucherait plf juillet peut-être
écouté y en a qui y évoque le fait
qu'ils seraient peut-être même presse
présenter comme candidat si monsieur
charest devient chef du parti
conservateur des gens son ancienne
équipe aussi christine st pierre madame
thériault aussi qu'est ce que ça veut
dire tout ça
si tout ce qui peut être le parti
conservateur souhaite compenser libéraux
du québec se sont re suffisant il faut
qu'ils trouvent des appuis chez les
conservateurs c'est bon ça nahman 108 la
politique qui nous invite monsieur
charest donc c'est un peu normal mais il
va falloir aller chercher quelque chose
de beaucoup plus profond que ça d'abord
comme un hymne à vienne s'expliquer aux
conservateurs pour que ceux ci le trouve
acceptable parce que
des choses qui sont carrément les lignes
impôts franchir le registre des armes à
feu en était un la taxe sur le carbone
dont le vue c'est ce qu'a eu la tête de
monsieur automatiquement donc il faudra
qu'il s'explique sur ces choses là et il
va falloir qu'il fasse entrer des
membres qui ne croit dax sur notre blog
par exemple c'est acceptable c'est
beaucoup de travail c'est beaucoup de
choses à faire et à merci parce que le 3
way et déjà il ya des attaques et déjà
hier soir ça paraissait une députée qui
est une de celles qui appuie clairement
pierre poilievre là qui s'appelle
shannon stop d'habitude l'alberta qui a
misé sur twitter le tableau qu'on va
vous montrer maintenant à l'écran elle
est simplement d'associer sur le plan
des valeurs et des positions le monsieur
charest avec monsieur trudeau finalement
montré regardez à quel point ce n'est
pas un conservateur elle sait ce que ce
genre d'attaqué qui peut porter
effectivement qui peut nuire à monsieur
charest
mais c'est les attaques du côté de
monsieur police à peu près une semaine
qu'on l'entend je pense qu'ils voulaient
vraiment découragé monsieur charest de
rentrer dans la course bon alors
monsieur charest c'est très bien je les
attaque qui vont venir mais il ya
beaucoup de consommateurs surtout au
sein du caucus monsieur poyet camp no 26
mais la majorité des gens ne se sont pas
prononcés encore plus beaucoup de
députés de l'ouest qui veulent juste
choisir un gagnant qui veulent quelqu'un
avec un petit peu plus de maturité que
monsieur poilievre qui est très
passionnant qui est en politique depuis
l'âge de 25 ans qui veulent quelqu'un
qui va peut-être unir le pays pas juste
la base conservatrice d'alors qui va
pouvoir aller chercher des appuis dans
les provinces atlantiques au québec
surtout en ontario puis ni entre ce que
ce qu'on m'a expliqué de la rencontre
hier monsieur charest aurait dit aux
députés de l'ouest que lui il serait
ouvert à l'idée d'une pipeline qui
traverse le territoire québécois c'est
peut-être seulement un québécois qui
pourrait faire vendre une pipe line de
l'ouest aux québécois mais ça je pense
que ça va l'aider la taxe sur le carbone
je pense pas que ça va être un aussi
gros en jeu que beaucoup on pense
maintenant oui une très forte base on
voyait monsieur poilievre aujourd'hui
s'attaquer à la taxe sur le carbone très
grosse base dans le parti conservateur à
l'instant qui ne voient pas c'est
insupportable pour eux d'avoir une taxe
de carbone mais sur la base de
consommatrices et 200 mille membres de
plus de 5 millions de gens qu'ils ont
voté pour le parti conservateur aux
élections
à l'automne dernier où mathilde temps
ces gens là en a beaucoup en ontario qui
pense que le futur c'est la plaque sur
le carbone elle elle va être déjà là ça
va faire plus de cinq ans est-ce que ce
que prochain premier ministre en lèvres
est vraiment puis il ya déjà qu'ils
veulent juste choisir c'est un winner
qui pense que monsieur charest y aurait
plus de chances de gagner de devenir
premier ministre dans une élection comme
chef bon ben ça vient positionner les
enjeux reste plus qu'à se présente pour
vrai qu'on regarde car elle et lui se
défend dans tous ces enjeux-là 60% non
plus merci beaucoup merci à vous tous
nos rois bon merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit